foreign
and welcome back to the deck
it's been a while and we know that some
of you have been eagerly waiting for a
chance to play our game we're working
very hard to make that happen as soon as
possible but in the meantime I brought a
special guest to introduce you all to an
aspect of scoring bones we haven't
talked much about yet which is our
narrative and how it works
in just a minute we'll be taking you
through about 40 minutes of exclusive
gameplay which we just recorded in our
studio
but before that let me introduce you all
to our world context with this short
trailer
the end of the 17th century
when ruthless corporations ruled the
Seas with an iron fist
they ignited a battle for Global
Supremacy to dominate the world the
world's most valuable trade routes
a flood of exotic goods from the Indian
Ocean stormed the West
creating new addictions
and a violent race for control
and where there's blood
there are predators
labeled as enemies of all mankind
this new breed of Pilots show no in
Mercy
sailing for Dangerous Waters they
created secret trading networks and
built their pirate Empires
they were always on the edge of losing
it all
and sink Into the Depths a skull and
bones
all right uh welcome back I hope you all
enjoyed this little introduction to our
world context I'm here today with drill
Hydro hi Alexi uh so drawers on
narrative director he works on
everything that I did Force Colin bonds
and today we're going to be showing you
a bit of that so can you tell us a
little bit more about what we're going
to show today Joe yeah we're going to
play an investigation Alexi and so
investigations and skull and bones are
really a way to tell a story through a
series of steps uh the player the player
kind of follows a trail of something
that they think is going to be
interesting and likely going to lead to
some kind of treasure or some kind of uh
score but it also tells a story about
our factions and our and our world and
we do that by
finding for example messages in bottles
scraps of lost journals sometimes
talking to different characters in the
world and through that we were able to
tell a story all right cool so I'm gonna
pick up the first clue of this
investigation I'm gonna read it out and
then we'll find out a bit more and we'll
talk about it a little bit together sure
the throne of grace ukuta is now
fortified against foreign Invaders and
our alliance with the Sudani of Soha
help ensure the prosperity of the
Confederation of unguana
the queen shall award a bountiful some
for information on capture of renegade
who has kept the stone of Justice
descended with a band of traitors and
met off with a royal crown of ukuta
rightfully belonging to Queen Elizabeth
the thieves and threaters were seen in
several Villages within the realm
including panda
by Royal Decree
all others and avatars shall be killed
bless her majesty
all right so that's the first clue and
basically what's happening there is a
little bit of a fight between brother
and sister both of them believe that
they're the right forehead to the throne
um but the brother basically ran away
with the crown right so for us as
pirates we're not really interested in
the tanky sides we're not really
interested in who's right who's wrong
what we are interesting however is the
mention of that crown and potential
treasure waiting for us of course
so what we're gonna do first uh the
first crew is basically telling us that
we need to find out where the brother
went uh he's been sliding uh in bandari
settlement so we're going to be selling
uh towards that destination
but before we do that maybe you can tell
us a little bit about the region we're
in and how does it fit with our world
context well so in the world context
this is the Golden Age of piracy and so
um where this game is a historical
fiction and so we're really basing a lot
of our choices in the game on uh being
inspired by the region of the Indian
Ocean and the factions that can be found
there at that time and during this time
period
um there is a desire from the West for
all the luxurious Goods that were
discovered here by the West that
discovered from their point of view and
uh and and there was a kind of a battle
for for who would have Supremacy over
those goods and of course uh that also
leads to battles with the local factions
and it's really the mega corporations
from the West stealing from the local
factions to feed those new addictions in
the west so there we see the dawn of the
modern economy uh yeah all right very
cool uh nice uh little introduction
there
um so because we know where we're going
it's a bit of a distance to sail so I've
now traveled to another Outpost and
maybe you can tell us a bit more about
the role that Outpost in in the game
yeah so outposts are really places to
explore find find lore uh from a
narrative point of view there's always
lore to be found in Outpost but more
than that there are also places to trade
to pick up contracts to cash in
contracts to sometimes pay off factions
if you have an aggro with a specific
faction it's also a place you can kind
of meet other players and socialize with
other players as well right of course
demo fully multiplayer
um cool so now we know that our next
destination is going to be that binary
settlement
um I'm going to talk about it a bit
later as we get closer to it but our
object is going to be to plunder that
settlement to find the next screw right
yes but for now as we're sitting maybe
there's more you can tell us about the
the exact region we're in and and the
regions of Scotland bones in general
yeah so we're in the coast of Africa
region here and as you can see from the
landscape it's a bit of a arid landscape
compared to some of the others in the
game and uh here there's there's two
major factions uh there's the
confederation of iguana who are really
more of the local faction who've
historically been here and they're a
nomadic faction and quite um aggressive
faction in terms of the game but the
thing about the the people from the
confederation of iguana is that they're
nomadic partially by circumstances and
the part of those circumstances is the
fact that the company Royale has moved
into the location and the company Royale
is really a mega Corporation from France
and they're the colonial power who is
disrupted the lives of the Confederation
of iguana and there's a whole back story
and quite a bit of
quite a bit of lore that can that can
build up that sort of relationship yeah
so one of the cool things about about
oldies as well is that as we are sailing
through and we see all the ships messing
us
um the more you play the game the more
we find out that these ships actually
have a lot of elements on them that are
giving you information right first of
all you can see the the equipments they
have so
ships we've just passed for example they
were equipped with a little cargo but
also the sales and the the emblems they
have will tell you which faction do they
belong to and stuff like that right yeah
of course so there's visual identifiers
you know we there's there's all kinds of
things that uh really help uh bring
authenticity to the different factions
in the game whether it's visual
linguistic you name it so a lot of work
went into like making sure that when
you're sailing through the coast of
Africa you feel that you're actually on
the coast of Africa absolutely
um there's also a lot of other elements
like the wildlife the the vegetation the
all these things that make you really
feel like you are actually sitting in
the coast of Africa which is very nice
yeah and if you want you can there is
wildlife in the waters that it can be
hunted by players but not with the ships
that we're sailing right now uh of
course you know Skull and Bones has all
different kinds of ships and you're
encouraged to use those different ships
in different ways some are better for
combat some are better for fast uh
navigation some for carrying large loads
and of course there are very small
shifts that can go through narrow
waterways and are useful for essentially
hunting water-based animals and so that
is an opportunity that we could explore
in the coast of Africa but because I
think we're trying to complete our
investigation we'll have to do that
instead so I know that there's actually
a lot of reviews to explore this
um luckily Force the rules we're in now
are large enough for us to sail with
those rather large ships yep but like
you said like some Rivers you're going
to have you're going to have to
basically switch to a smaller state
which might not be as well equipped but
that'll be the only way to get some of
the resources that the region has to
offer right yep and so it pays to have a
varied Fleet of ships it's fair to say
yes
all right so we're going to get closer
to that uh settlement in just a little
bit
um there's uh yeah there's a couple of
information that we need to keep in mind
when we get closer first of all uh so so
far nobody's really bothering about us
because we're just not being very
aggressive right but the moment we
attack the settlement that's going to
change obviously yeah uh that settlement
belongs to the to the local faction
um but we are we're not here to actually
plunder any resources we're here to find
the crew so what we're going to do
before we start the plundering is we are
going to plan our Escape Route to make
sure that we don't get into too much
trouble okay uh so yeah I'm almost there
now uh but essentially yeah that's
that's the key thing about Skylanders
when you want to engage the combat
depending on your objective you want to
make sure you're prepared for it so if
you want to plunder it all the way then
you need to make sure you're ready for a
long fight on the other hand if you're
just looking for one specific item then
you want to plan and escape and you want
to make sure that you can run away uh
without getting too much heat
um yeah because the way the the way the
plunder feature works is that the longer
the fight goes on the harder it gets the
more there's going to be reinforcements
and the more aggressive these
reinforcements are going to get but if
I've learned anything playing the game
things will go wrong so let's see so
hopefully uh we'll make it alive
all right so I'm gonna drop anchor Now
open up my map
and I'm gonna set my Escape Route for uh
that shipwreck on the far East
and whenever we're ready let's get
started I'm ready all right let's go
do this
so as you can see here A bunch of our a
bunch of our crew are jumping overboard
to essentially enter the settlement and
begin the plundering action and so
the fantasy here is uh as we're out here
fighting and holding our ground there in
the settlement uh scampering around you
know stealing whatever they can get
their hands on and looking for the thing
that in this case we're looking for
which is the next Clevelander
investigation and as you can see those
those different uh stops across the top
of the screen of the of what will happen
during the plundering action if we
survive is uh they will start sending
out what they find while our crew is is
in there on small ships for us to pick
up so if they do their job right we will
get our crew in the first package yeah
and then we can make our Escape
obviously the longer the battle goes on
the more at risk we're at here in this
kind of confined space yeah but that's
also uh that's also how you get the
highest rewards right exactly so uh if
you can stick it out all the way to the
end of course you're gonna plunder a
heck of a lot but as you can see here we
are facing stiff uh stiff competition
yeah so my my strategy usually when we
plant the settlement is at the beginning
is pretty chill I want to say all things
considered yep so what I try to do is I
try to damage the tower first before all
the big reinforcements come in but in
that case the beginning a lot of heat
from those flame floors yes it's not
super chill at the moment yeah it turns
out and the tower is also I see that
you're taking some heavy hits from the
tower
yeah
um and that's the thing like depending
on the enemy you're facing obviously you
can see that there's different weak
spots you can hit for extra damage but
they're also gonna have different kind
of weapons who might inflict different
kind of damage on your ship so you need
to be kind of prepared for that as well
yes
um having a well-rounded strategy never
hurts because as we mentioned things
will go wrong and it is quite uh it is
quite chaotic at the moment but I think
we're almost there yeah I'm just gonna
just go look through so now we can run
away let's do it for all the Big Trouble
Comes perfect if you just follow me I I
I know where we're going okay
all right so like you can see on the
screen we're leaving the prando area now
so that means any uh potential loot
extra loot that we could have gotten
will be full faded at this point
um boy but we don't care because we have
what we need yeah our Escape is not yet
guaranteed though yes
that's fair to say
and there's uh like you were saying
before there's a the company Royal
fighting here with the local faction so
you can see some of that conflict
happening right here yeah and that
that's part of the Living World of skull
and bones and in this case I think it's
going to work to our advantage here
because uh the com the confederation of
iguana is going to be sort of torn about
who to aggro more us or the company
right now
all right so far so good I'm gonna use
it to pick it just to
fix my ship a little bit yep
I've seen better days
how's it looking for you are you able to
make it in our life yeah I'm gonna be
okay I'm I I'm kind of running close to
this company Royale ship so I'm gonna be
curious to see
they don't seem to have any issue with
us but
um hopefully oh yeah
yep so they're under attack from the
confederation of iguana which is great
news because that means I'm getting away
it's quite iron I think that we're being
saved by the same people that we just
attacked yes
but I think it's looking good when I uh
this on my side it's looking like it's
gonna be quiet
passing the Shipwreck here yeah there's
a lot of flamethrower action behind you
all right so I'm gonna drop anchor
around here and I'm gonna start reading
the next clue
King wenya has landed in bandari Harbor
they're still wearing his crown he is
but a shell of the man he once was Queen
hallisi has taken the throne and
strengthened her alliances within the
realm
with Union kevu and Desperation he
pleads for help
to see such groveling from royalty
Khaleesi spies are everywhere those who
do not pledge allegiance are being
seized and executed
Prudence is vital
for this reason I had to turn away the
beligan king and beseech him to return
to great ukuta and ask for
reconciliation his sister might be
merciful
my police fell on deaf ears
has disagreed
the dethroned King has departed together
allies to the North and defied the use
of
an undeterred when your cells towards
his feet
may peace be with him
what goes around and when your ship has
vanished to south of Jewish settlement
I fear the worst
lost too sadly is the crown of ukuta but
for the best perhaps as the usopa queen
is caused to rule without the ancestral
crowd foreign
[Music]
between sister and brother is not
looking good to be honest it looks like
they still they can't find an agreement
basically
um so King Winnie ran away with the
crown the queen well the sister Queen is
basically destined to rule Without a
Crown but for our interests we've been
told to look for the next clue at the
Shipwreck next to Jewish so that's where
we're going to sell now all right
uh the other thing I noticed what I was
reading the clue is that um there's
actually some graphics that you can
display that shows the clue written in a
language that I don't really understand
or concrete so if you can tell us more
about this yeah I mean we are obviously
inspired by the the people of the region
and so we've worked really closely with
historians as well as language and
culture experts to make sure that we're
we're being accurate and being taking
that inspiration as far as we can in
terms of uh showing the authenticity
that that comes from the different
factions in this region or I should say
from portraying the different factions
in this region
and uh yeah another another thing that I
like a lot about you know talking about
Regional factions and Regional cultures
uh is the shanties I'm gonna play one
right now so maybe you can talk to us a
bit more about shanties in the game yeah
so uh the way I see it is we really have
three different types of shanties in the
game of course we have your classic
pirate shanties that I think people uh
come to expect myself included but we
also have some language specific
shanties like we were talking about some
that are not translated and are kept uh
in the language of the local factions
which I think is very cool and really
exciting and in addition to that we also
have certain shanties that are really
specific to the world lore of our game
so
shanty's about the the characters in our
game about some of the legendary
kingpins about some of the myths and the
overall fantasy of our game nice very
nice
um so yeah as we sitting a bit uh we can
enjoy the consumeries and change engine
lighting as we get closer to night time
um and one thing I like as well when I'm
sailing and there's not too much combat
or action going on is taking advantage
of the different cameras that we have in
our game
yeah absolutely I mean if you take the
time to make your ship look awesome you
want to celebrate it when you have a
moment you know
I mean that's the that's the key thing
about apparent right you take pride into
making a ship impressive and good
looking and exactly
you work just like just like your hand
is going to be encrusted with rings you
also got to have your [ __ ] impressive
with cool stuff yes uh and then the
other thing that I find are both at a
quite fun but also very distracting is
obviously the world is really big right
and you said cell thinking okay I'm
gonna go look for something specific and
then as you said sell you look around
and you see one thing interesting and if
you like me you'll get tempted to find
out what it is and then you lose
you lose focus basically and you get
distracted by other things and you
forget why you went while you were at
Sea in the first place but that's all
right we're happy to uh we're happy to
have players get lost in our world
that's that's part of the goal and I
think that was part of what it was like
to be a pirate was to I guess see
opportunities and seize them in the
moment
so yeah but in our case we can't get
distracted because our time is limited
we're on a mission yes and I'm now
arriving to that [ __ ] wreck we're
looking for
so I'm just gonna get a little closer uh
drop anchor and
and then I'll read the next clue great
all right
dear sister
your betrayal is complete
yeah I lie bleeding from Mortal wounds
and contemplating the afterlife at the
table of our ancestors
All That Remains of my domain is that
the how and some Mega Russians
your Venom poisons our lands
your cruelty has trampled the hopes of
even my most loyal followers who
abandoned me at the first chance
of the cost of pandari we were boarded
by Pirates led by one Captain Freeman
who seduced my crew with Promises of
freedom from servitude in a secret Haven
Anita
let them go
I'd rather die fighting as a king
Noble in his clothes than ever living
moment as a common role
alas
without a clue
my ship ran aground
and I was injured
please
remain at my side
through service
to the end
even now they tell me to stop writing as
it is time to join my ancestors at peel
a tomb
the next World beckons me
they will offer
Carry Me
I will walk myself
into the center
sacred stone circles
crown
Uncle John
shall never be yours
remains mine
okay so it looks like the story is
taking a quite a dramatic uh turn
towards the end uh there's a couple of
things I've learned from that crew
actually the first one is after years of
working in that game I finally found out
how to pronounce the how I didn't know
it was pronounced that way but the other
thing is uh so like like the story said
basically the king Winnie had a very
unfortunate uh encounter he met a
certain Captain Freeman who then
convinced his entire crew to basically
abandon him and live free in a place
called and Mitra yeah
um so maybe you can tell us more about
this Freeman and yeah so Captain Freeman
is really uh a mythical character I like
to say he's part of the foundational
myth of our world and so Captain Freeman
has a story that you're gonna put
together in the game by doing all these
different investigations you'll get
little Snippets about Captain Freeman
from every investigation to put together
a full picture of who he was and one
thing that is known widely is that he
was part of what was called at the time
or what we call the heist of the century
meaning that he he took part in the
biggest score any pirate had ever done
in our world by doing a massive score
against the Dutch Merchant company and
so he was one of the also founding
members of this sort of pirate Den
borderline pirate Paradise called the
Nitra
and in lenitra it was very much an
egalitarian almost Democratic Society
where Pirates supported each other
worked together really began to work
against the mega corporations in a quite
coordinated way
um and it included uh even some of the
other characters that we'll meet in our
game like one of our major characters
John Scurlock for example was was an
inhabitant of uh uh lenitra but
um tragically lenitra was destroyed
being attacked by those the company Roy
Allen the DMC the Dutch Merchant company
given the events of the heist of the
century and some of the other things
that um
Captain Freeman and his ilk got up to
and so
uh really that that whole idea that
whole idea of having this this like
pirate Utopia has been destroyed in the
mythology of our game and what we're
left with now is a world that is much
more Cutthroat much more doggy dog it is
a much harsher and grittier pirate world
than that mythical pirate past that some
of the characters in our world can
remember it's no more safe heaven for us
to to live our life sweet and and
Freeman himself is sort of a mystery
lost to time that hopefully we can learn
more about by doing those investigations
all right so I know there's a lot more
to that story and uh we'll probably
leave that for players to find out when
uh when they find the it's playoff game
in open Beta at lunch absolutely um
but one thing I need you to tell me and
I don't know if you can answer that
question uh was Freeman a good guy or
bad guy uh I think you know his first
Pirates ago he was a good guy he did he
did uh he did believe in the sort of
utopian vision of lenitra and he did
want to do right by uh the the little
guy so to speak and uh his his his goal
was really to take issue with the mega
corporations fair enough but I guess in
our game it all it's it's all a matter
of perspective right you can depending
on how you feel and which side you want
to be on there's no real good guy no I
mean even the best good guy is still
gonna have gray area uh to take issue
with I mean Pirates are pirates right
yeah and it's a it's a difficult world
right so being a hundred percent good in
that world will probably not get you
very far exactly right
um so while we're talking uh we just
arrived at the our final destination our
third Auto is called the pilot Tom
um I'm gonna show you a little bit how
that place looks because it looks quite
amazing uh but I also want to I would
like to ask you a bit more about NPCs in
the game in general and and like
different vendors and
yeah so we have vendors or Hawkers you
might call them who are the people who
are really going to sell you all the
different things in the world that
you're able to buy and consume and there
is many I mean when it comes to think
ingredients for upgrading your ship
um things to feed your crew
things for upgrading your weapons
upgrading your appearance all those
kinds of things you're going to get
through Hoggers as well as
the ability to take on new contracts New
Opportunities maybe even pay off
factions like for example if we had an
ongoing feud with the confederation of
iguana based on our plunder earlier we
could potentially pay off somebody at a
at a Outpost like this who's related to
that faction
um
but uh in in addition to those
characters we also have pirate kingpins
in our world and so I mentioned John
Scurlock a minute ago he's one of the
first pirate kingpins that players are
going to meet and he you know he really
stands as a an example of the kind of
Kingpin the player is going to want to
become
cool
uh so I like that you said he's one of
the first because I know there's more I
know we can't talk about it yet but I
know there's more
um and uh correct me if I'm wrong but I
also believe that when you start
engaging with those uh kingpins they
will look at you based on your
reputation they will look at you based
on your actions and depending on that
you might get different contracts
absolutely I mean uh the whole the whole
world of skull and bones is about infamy
and so the player wants to the player
really starts as an outcast and they
want to rise and become an Infamous
Kingpin and so those contracts and those
relationships you're going to build with
other kingpins are going to grow and
change based on your infamy in the world
and actually
one of the things I'm really proud of is
the whole world of skull and bones is
very reactive so the actions the player
does the infamy they gain the player
wreck the the other characters in the
world really recognize it and respond to
that
cool
um another thing I really like about uh
Outpost in general
um is that sometimes you're just walking
around not really sure you know you're
not necessarily looking for anything
specific in our case we are looking for
something specific I'm just you know
enjoying this you know a little bit uh
but then every now and then you pass by
something and you hear it sounds and uh
I know that there's a lot of stuff in
the game out there and I've asked around
like
what's going on and nobody really knows
well there are there are certainly
surprises Treasures tricks and and
everything to be found in these areas
in these outposts
and I will spoil nothing yeah no and
there's a lot there's a lot to discover
I I
played the game quite a lot myself and
there's a lot of apples I still haven't
fully explored so
so all that being said I still haven't
found this uh treasure so from the clue
if I remember correctly it said that uh
the treasures buried in a stone circle
grave kind of thing
um so I'm gonna try to find this sure
uh full spoiler I actually know where it
is so I know I'm going but I'm just
gonna pretend I don't know right right
um but yeah it's it's pretty it's it's
it can be hard to find if you don't know
what you're looking for once you know
what you're looking for it's pretty
obvious
yeah and it's important to pay close
attention to the clues actually for
investigations investigations are not
meant to be uh straightforward they're
meant to be something that we have to
it's not going to be a big marker
telling you where to go so that's right
all right so I think I found the the
grave now and I can dig up the treasure
chest so I'll just be waiting for you a
little bit and then we'll take it out
all right let's dig it out
I think
nice
nice
perfect
so yeah as you can see I see I found the
treasure decked it out uh and that
should give us the last piece of
information for investigation
um which will allow us to complete the
investigation so I'm gonna read that
last uh bit of info so that we get the
kind of a closure to the story
sheltered from the tyrannical eye of the
userpa Queen by the guardian's spirit of
our ancestors
at the behest of our King we take the
crown of kuta and depart to the north
far from the Queenstown malevolence
I pray that King will be honored by our
ancestors
Azizi loyal servant of his majesty
nwenya
all right so the sad news here is that
there will be no crown for us uh as we
learned from that last bit of info the
the crown was taken away by the Servants
of um winier and I don't think there's
ever going to be a chance for us to find
it who knows no uh the good news is we
did get a little reward for us uh for
completing the investigation but before
I equip it on my ship can you tell us a
bit more about all the investigations in
the game yeah well and like like we
mentioned we do also one of the things
we did get is a piece of a larger story
about Eureka Freeman so all the other
investigations are going to obviously
give some promise of treasure and reward
but also we'll fill in some more of the
gaps about Eureka Freeman and his story
um and because we know Freeman did the
heist of the century and no one knows
for sure whatever happened to the
treasure that was taken in that Heist
um there there's some hope that by
completing all the investigations that
we may be the ones who ultimate really
find it cool exciting uh so that that
reward I just equipment on my ship is a
vanity item is new figureheads so I can
show you a bit more now uh but maybe you
can tell us a bit more like uh what is
the connection between vanity in our
game and the local factions can we get
items from the local factions to
customize our ships and our captain
absolutely
um we we can and we can get all kinds of
different ones to to spice it up in
different ways that by the looks of it
the one you have there uh it seems to be
the Eureka Freeman uh emblem I think
that symbol of a hammer it comes from
his backstory and uh yeah that looks
very cool all right
and that was it for us uh today thank
you very much Joe for coming on the show
and talking to us about the game and
narrative my pleasure thanks Alexi all
right we'll see you all very soon thank
you very much bye
thanks a lot to all of you for tuning in
today and watching our show I hope this
answered some of your questions but also
encourages you to answer some more we
know there's still a lot of things you
would like to know about our game
how far can you go with customization
how deep are combat mechanics what our
monetization plans or even how much
content will be added after release
these are all topics we intend to
address through future episodes of the
deck our Dev blog and on social media so
keep an eye out and I'll see you again
very soon